so hi again I'm Lea
so I was introduced quite nicely thank
you but here's a fun fact you don't know
about me I grew up in the Greek island
of Lesbos which technically makes me
geographically lesbian this is something
that not many people know about me so if
you've ever heard about me before it's
probably from one of my open-source
projects
I'm also the census working group which
just means that I've gotten better at
spending increasing amounts of time
discussing issues of decreasing
importance and then the last year I've
been exploring the wondrous world of
academia and trying my luck at research
I'm doing a human-computer interaction
research basically trying to make it
easier to create web applications mainly
data-driven web applications so enough
about me
oh and I've written the book if you have
it I can sign it just find me in one of
the breaks or the party so enough about
me
let's move on to something more
interesting such as pie charts pie
charts are everywhere in xkcd in old
windows on walls on genitals on food on
blackboards and of course there they're
very ubiquitous on the web we see pie
charts all the time elf wave for evil to
show percentages or just as spinners to
for as a loading indicator but still
it's surprisingly difficult to make them
with web technologies for example look
at this very very simple pie chart this
is what we'll be working on for most of
this talk how can we make this pie chart
with web technologies it's super simple
it's just two colors it should be very
easy right can you think of a solution
can you try to think about it for a bit
just a very simple tight
thing needs to go it needs to show one
percentage from zero to 100% how would
you do it so when I thought about it my
first idea was okay we need to show
custom angles in some way
let's try skew transforms so we start
with a square element we give it a
border radius of 50% to make it round
and then we add a pseudo element with an
empty content we position it absolutely
let's give it a background as well to
see what we're doing right now it won't
show because it has no dimensions bottom
50% left
50% and let's give it a padding of 50%
as well now we're starting to see it
let's give this overflow:hidden so that
it doesn't obscure our code and it looks
more like a pie chart so this already
looks like a pie chart with 25% more
scape like most times the 1 25% won't be
what we want
so this is where transforms come in
let's try skewing transform so we're
sort of starting to get there but not
quite because this is not exactly
staying in the center but you know how
to fix that right we just use the
transform origin or bottom left and now
it looks more like a pie chart
hey thank you but wait a bit because yes
we can show different percentages but as
it grows it starts showing the problems
which you we can sort of patch by
increasing the bad thing but at some
point it will come back to bite us we
can increase the padding even more
whether I can't make it infinite so that
90 degrees it will disappear but we can
sort of get around that we can special
case everything we can special case 50%
because it's easy to just give it a
different colour and have the the on
half the the circle the difficult part
was showing the angles right and we can
give it a SAN over half class and apply
and change the transform and append the
color and swap the colors to show
percentages over 50% so we can we can
sort of do it with skewed suit of
elements so there I sold it I made pie
charts with CSS is it good is it a good
solution would you work would you want
to work on this code would anybody want
to work on this code doesn't it make you
feel dirty that we used CSS and that in
such a way and pure CSS is not good
enough just using CSS to mate is to just
claim hey I did this with pure CSS so
what will you CSS because of its the
clarity of reactive nature because
sometimes it actually helps us simplify
our code just being able to do something
in CSS without actually ending up with
code that's maintainable or or even
understandable that what the hell does
this do how do I set this pie charts to
show 30% I will have to say think that
Oh minus 90 degrees was zero and then 90
degrees was 50% so 30 bit seriously
nobody wants to think to think like that
usually we should just be able we should
be able to just set a straightforward
number so to sorry for a super CSS
solution to actually be a good idea it
needs to be flexible it needs to be
maintainable and ideally it should be
extensible that's not as important but
it should be it's
good thing if it's also extensible and
flexibility means multiple things such
as is it possible to change things what
things well you can sort of foresee what
you might want to change about something
in the pie chart example you might want
to change the colors or of course you
will want to set the percentage so these
things should be possible to change but
it shouldn't they should just be
possible to change it should be possible
to change them in line ideally because a
lot of the time we'll have a widget that
we stylist with CSS and then we change
something with JavaScript and with
JavaScript we can only set inline Styles
yes with CSS variables that won't be a
big problem because we can just set the
CSS variable and then we can use it in
pseudo elements so that won't be a
problem but right now if we need to
change something in a pseudo element to
modify the percentage that's a problem
because we can't in like we can't set
pseudo elements by inline Styles and if
you're wondering by the way CSS
variables have pretty bad browser
support right now so it's still a
concern so and also it's not just about
being possible to change and being
possible to change it in line but also
how easy is it to change and how many
places do I have to change stuff to make
a simple edit because the more edits I
have to do the more the more likely it
is that I will forget one and or that
the future developer after me will
forget one or they will not even know
how that they need to make changes all
over the place so it's software
engineering this is called don't repeat
yourself
so the acronym is dry dry code is a good
thing strive to make your code as dry as
possible the opposite who's wet by the
way we enjoy typing good CSS solutions
should also be maintainable which is
also sort of it's hard to define but a
heuristic and it's just a heuristic
because you can have tons of code that
is very understandable very well
commented it's just a rule of thumb the
more code usually the more effort it
takes to understand it also in the case
of HTML CSS does it require
extra elements do I need to add extra
elements to make this work that's a
problem because it makes I have to it I
have to change two things to make the
solution work so it's sort of it it's
more things that I have to know about
the code to work on it and is it
straightforward that's which which
cannot be strictly defined but you know
when the code you've written is not
straightforward right you know that this
to skew the pseudo-element example is
not straightforward in any definition of
the word right it's it feels hacky it
feels bad it feels like this is not what
we should be doing that means it's
usually it's not maintainable and
extensibility is how easy it is to add
more things in the future how easy is it
to extend what it does for example in
the in the pie chart case can I add
multiple segments what if I don't want
to just show one percentage but I want
to show multiple that's it something
that we can foresee doing can we do it
or do we have to completely change how
we're styling our pie chart also can we
have a patient can can we animate either
the whole thing and make and turn it
into a spinner or just the pie the pie
segments as they appear can we show them
with a transition or can I have effect
can I color the segments with gradients
for instance or patterns or something so
in the case of the skewed Suellen pseudo
elements yeah I can change the colors in
one place I can change the size in one
place I need to make four edits to
change the value ah well in the simple
case I can only make one at it if I'm
changing it from 10% to 20% in the
general case I need to make four edits
if if it goes from below 50% to above
50% and it's not possible to set the
value in line because my transform is in
the pseudo element so I can't set that
in line the good thing is it's not using
any extra elements it is using 14
declaration in four rules which for a
simple tried pie chart are a bit too
many and it's terribly messy in hockey
most importantly extensibility wise I
can sort
have multiple segments I can sort of
animate I can sort of do some effects
it's a pain in the ass to do any of
these so it's sort of okay but still
overall the skewed sewer element is a
bad idea can we do better let's let's
try to think of a better idea how can we
show custom angles in a circle in CSS
how could we show custom angles we we
try to secure transforms it didn't work
very well what else do we have
we have rotations can we do it can we
make it work with rotations what if we
call it our circle half of it being our
base color this f06
this magenta and the other half being
gold stay with me here
so let's try to do that for a bit so now
I have a gradient but it would turn it
will turn into what I've described very
quickly so these will come together and
actually this doesn't even need to be 50
it could be anything it could be zero as
long as it's smaller than the previous
one it works so I will tend to use zero
and all the in any gradients you might
see in the future in this talk it just
means it's equal to the previous one the
browser does this for you so you don't
have to type it twice so there I've
colored my circle with two colors so now
what if I add a pseudo element that is
also magenta f06 let's set this and I
move it to the side by margin left 50% I
give it a height of a hundred percent
and of course now it's square I could
either solve it this by overflow:hidden
or I could solve this by nice use of
border radius so I want to make it a
semi circle right so 50% won't work what
will work is if I use the extended
border radius syntax which lets me set
the different
on every corner both horizontally and
vertically so I let's think about it I
want a semicircle on the bright side so
the top right the top left corner is
zero has has no rounding horizontally
the top bright one has a hundred percent
the bottom right one has a hundred
percent and the top-right one has a
hundred percent and sorry zero and
vertically it's fifty percent so there
we have it I can give it a different
color if you don't believe me that this
is actually my element it is my element
so it's a semicircle now and this is
where the magic begins because now I can
start rotating it and it's almost almost
getting there what do I need transform
origin which will be on the left center
so left and there it is now so you might
be wondering why is this better than the
previous one well for one I don't have
weird artifacts when I get to a hundred
and eighty I just need to change one
thing and it works and also it still
needs us it still needs a class to get
to the show percentages over 50 percent
ha but the only thing that's needed here
to show percentages over 50 percent is
to set a background of gold to my pseudo
element and then I can show any
percentage I want over 50 percent see
the bottom pile I can show any
percentage I want on it so it's sort of
slightly slightly more straightforward
you might start thinking well I've
repeated my colors and stuff in many
places so that's not very maintainable
yes I have but I can eliminate that
repetition let's eliminate the
repetition so here I've set it to f06
but it's in a gradient so I can't really
use it anywhere else instead I'm gonna
set it to transparent and I'm gonna move
the color as a background color so now
instead of retyping f06 here I can just
inherit but if I just didn't hear it on
the background you see what happens
because it inherits the whole to color
background so I have to show it to
change this the background color also
okay you might be thinking okay you did
this with the background color but what
will you do about gold because otherwise
we would have to repeat it here well
actually we don't because I can just set
the color to gold and then I changed
this gradient color stop to current
color which always refers to the value
of the color property if I change this
to say green then it changes in the
gradient so now I can set this to
current color as well because color is
an inherited property so my studio
element also has a color of gold and now
if I change it it changes in both places
and also I can make this a little more
sensible by using turn units so now this
is 10% and a corresponds to point one
turn so I don't have to do weird weird
math with angles 20% 30% and so on and
yes above above 50%
it would have to reset again like 50%
corresponds to zero turns and 60% is
point one turns but compared to what we
had to endure with the skewed hack with
the skewed element hack that's slightly
better and can I animate it with it with
the skew transform it was a it was a
huge pain to even attempt animation on
it here it's not super straightforward
but we can do it we will need to animate
two things the color and the rotation so
the color will go from
we'll alternate between current color
and inherit and the spender rotation
will also will go from 0 to 0.5 tonnes
and we have to remove this one it just
gets the default of 0 by the way you
notice I didn't use from and two key
frames this is because when you don't
specify from a new key frame or from or
two key frames the browser generates
them for you so in this animation the
from key frame is just rotate zero which
is the state of this rule that will
apply it on so we set the color over we
animate the color over two seconds
actually let's do it wrong first so that
you see what happens this will be linear
they will both be infinite oh and here
we're doing a background color again not
background so you can see the problem
the caller doesn't actually abruptly
change it smoothly changes which is
usually great this is why we love CSS
animations in this case though we wanted
it to abruptly change it's 50% so what
do we do we specify an animation timing
function of step start and when we apply
it there we have an animating pie chart
now however we might be thinking well
what we actually wanted was not an
animated pie chart it was just a simple
little tiny static pie chart we just
wanted to show different percentages on
a static pie chart so what can we do the
thing is the browser knows how to
progress an animation what if we could
just tell the browser stop the animation
at 10 percent or stop the animation at
50 percent stop the animation at 80
percent
this is exactly what we want to display
a percentage and then we would be able
to just change one value and display a
custom percentage why don't we have
something like this in CSS like an
interpolate function or something like
this well sadly we don't but we can hack
it with what I call static interpolation
which is not actually a real thing
interpolation is when you is figuring
out the intermediate states between two
keyframes and static just means that I'm
basically going to be using an animation
but nothing will actually animate so
let's let's examine it first on a
simpler animation let's write the
keyframes rule here let's call it foo
and let's make it go from gold to f06
you'll see a lot of f06 here it's my
favorite color
so let's attach it here let's give it
two seconds or maybe five whatever and
you can see how it switches from gold to
f06 and the browser knows all the
intermediate stages but how could we
make it how could we say I want the
background to be 50% between gold and
f06
there's no function for that however
what we could do is there is a property
animation play state which is by by
default it has the value the value
running but it can get the value post
which poses our animation okay big deal
you might be thinking I would just have
gold and nothing else yes but we have
this amazing property called animation
delay which doesn't look like much when
you first see it because it's basically
it may delay your animation by a bit so
we've animated but your normal animation
from gold to f06 would look like this
over time say with a 10 second duration
an animation delay of one second would
shift it over time and it would start
one second later not very useful right
but you can have negative
and delay and what did let what that
does it shifts it on the other direction
so you can actually step through your
animation and if your animation is
paused what you get is this the study of
creams that the browser generated and no
animation so let's try this let's use
that seconds here and animation delay
say - 5 seconds so yep I'm not sure if
you if it shows very much but we're
basically stepping through the animation
it starts showing you an awful lot like
f06 after a certain point alright
because we need to make it linear
otherwise its accelerates after a
certain point so after 50% the values
are very similar so yes this is actually
50% between these two colors and let's
make it a hundred so that these actually
correspond to percentages so this is 50%
this is 25% this is 75% and 99% what do
you expect - 100 seconds to show it
should show f06 right nope and the
reason for that is that basically you're
stepping through the animation as if it
actually was it was actually playing
it's just that it's paused but it's it's
the same thing as if it was playing and
what happens to an animation of it after
it finishes it snaps back to the
beginning unless you use animation film
mode for words and then this means when
the animation ends freeze the last frame
and just show me that I don't want you
to snap back to the beginning I don't
want you to do anything just show me the
last frame and you don't even need a
separate property because it's part of
the animation shorthand so you can just
add it here so let's go back to our pie
chart here
let and let's convert it to use
animation delay first we remove the
infinite iterations because we don't
need that anymore we'll just be
statically going through it we do need
to add two iterations here because its
duration is half and then we add
forwards to both of them or actually
it's probably best to do a separate
declaration here just so that we don't
repeat it
remember dry and animation delay let's
ah let's make this a hundred so that we
actually have numbers that could do
correspond to percentages since the
durations don't really matter anymore
and our animation play state as well
because right now you see it's playing
it's very slow but it's still playing
let's pause it let's set a delay of say
minus ten seconds and let's reapply it
yes this is ten seconds we want to show
20 percent yes this is 20 percent 30
percent and so on we can just set the
percentage by changing one number and it
works even at a hundred percent so this
is already a huge improvement you might
be thinking though
thank you you might be thinking though
this is inside the pseudo-element we
can't set inline styles and pseudo
elements so okay you made it changeable
by one property but what good does it do
may still can set it by a JavaScript but
we don't have an animation on the main
element do we so animation delay on the
main element won't do anything right so
I can just inherit it here and then I
can set it on the main element and this
could be an inline style
thank you so rotated pseudo-element
one cut one edit to change the color one
to two edits this change the size one
edit to change the value that's the big
improvement here and we can set it in
line very big improvement it doesn't use
any extra elements still has a lot of
code somewhat less hacky but still can
affordable you can't have multiple
segments that's a pretty big limitation
because you know pie charts often used I
often show multiple percentages it is
possible to animate we've already seen
it we can't really do any effects due to
how it works and this whole happiness of
like uncovering half of the circle know
that maybe we can do a few limited
effects but not really so overall it's
not really that great so can we do
better how
well we could use SVG and the reason SVG
the thought of using SVG on this would
give most people shivers is because most
people would think of doing pie charts
by this way very little CSS and a path
with very weird numbers you can see this
path syntax what does it do how does it
work how many people here can understand
what all these numbers here do yeah only
the person who created SVG I can
actually tell you what they do the first
command moves it to 50/50 the the point
50 horizontally and C and 0 vertically
and then it draws an arc with the 50 50
the point 50 comma 50 is its center this
one and it throws an arc with a radius
of 50 to this point which is 40 point 80
on the coordinate system of the SVG
which have defined in the view box okay
and how do I figure out what point I
want how do I figure out what the end
point of the path should be for dica my
idea okay that makes sense because I
actually wanted to show a percentage of
like 30 something percent how do you
figure out these numbers I have to do a
lot of trigonometry and I would really
rather not is there any better solution
there is of course so here's an SV
here's another SVG it's it's an it's an
HTML element as well it's an inline SVG
so it has a class of Pi I've divided
defined its units as 64 width and 64
height you'll see soon why this weird
number it just makes some calculations
easier and it has a circle with 25% its
radius so what can we do with this per
circle we can style it with CSS we can
give it a stroke yeah the SVG version of
CSS is a little different we can cancel
its fill so that we don't have this
horrible none this horrible black we can
set stroke width and one is the default
where we can make it thicker
and there's also another property called
store stroke dezirae which lets us do
custom dashed borders in CSS this sets
the dash width this sets the dash gap so
you can do some pretty trippy things if
you increase the stroke as much as the
radius so that there's no circle and
just stroke oh and let's give it a
background because remember this points
to the SVG element which is just another
HTML element so you can give it normal
CSS properties like background or border
radius so we can do some pretty cool
stuff but okay let's not get distracted
because that's rays cool let's remember
we were trying to do pie charts
how do pie charts relate to this well I
could increase my gap a lot like
seriously a lot like as much as the
circumference of the circle and well I
could just do this by trial and error
I'll could just calculate what the
circumference is this is where these
weird numbers come in so my radius is
25% of what of 64 because that's my view
box so 25% of 64 and then remember
what's the formula for the circumference
of the circle two times pi times R we
have the R we need to multiply by 2 and
pi so this is our sin cumference a
little over a hundred and why is this
convenient because then as long as we
set the the gap width to be as much as
the circumference the dash width
basically corresponds to the percentage
we want to show in our pie so we can set
any percentage we want with just this
one property it corresponds to the
percentage were actually trying to show
okay I know what you're thinking it
doesn't have the right orientation let's
fix that remember we can play regular
CSS properties here so let's do - okay
and there we can show any percentage we
want just by adjusting this one number
can we animate hell yeah yeah I'm not
very good with names as you as you might
have noticed just foo and let's make
this zero
so there's our animation just one line
one simple animation one line two it's
basically as simple as it gets
and you can have multiple segments here
here's how I've used attributes here you
don't have to use attributes I've just
used them so I can have my whole thing
in one place SVG has these weird inline
Styles that are basically attributes but
they're different from inline Styles so
it has both it has inline Styles as well
and it has attributes attributes have
zero specificity so they're kind of like
the opposite of inline Styles if I apply
any CSS to this it's a the it overrides
the attributes but for all intents and
purposes in this case they treat Emma's
properties so you can just use - offset
if you want to have multiple segments
you can just add another circle give it
an offset so that it doesn't cover the
other one and you can have as many
segments as you want this is actually a
real pie chart you can see that most of
the CSS working group is member
companies like browsers basically so
next time somebody tells you that
browsers just have to implement whatever
standards w3c Springs on them you know
you know better flexibility we can
change the colors in with one edit we
can say is that we can change the size
within to edit we will probably make it
with one as well if we really try one
edit for the value we can set the value
in line yes we do need extra elements
but we can just write a short JavaScript
script to add these seven declarations
only it's the shortest solution we've
seen so far it's pretty straightforward
by the way if you're wondering about
accessibility any SVG element can have a
tight little child so you can just have
a title element inside it and all the
content you want multiple values are
possible it's easy to animate we've seen
it effects are possible don't mess it
because you have to use SVG syntax for
adding safe gradients or patterns and
it's not a great syntax but it's
possible
so overall the SVG stroke - array method
is pretty much beats both as which CSS
methods we've seen can we do better
so here's their night another idea how
many of you have heard about conic
gradients how many of you have heard
about Kony gradients in the context of
CSS cool nice so this is a conic
gradient
basically it's a ray changing color and
rotating around a fixed center point the
gradient I'm making right now has
nothing to do with pie charts
it's just a cool gradient it's basically
the hue wheel that you see on all color
Pickers
we would be able to do it with a conic
gradient and okay let's not get
distracted pie charts pie charts so how
do these help us do pie charts well we
can just have a conic gradient like this
with two stops there it is
remember zero is equal to thirty percent
but so that we can change the
percentages one place so yeah basically
it's one line of code and we can show
all the percentages we want just with
this one line do we
thank you and what if we want multiple
segments well easy-peasy there you go
that's not a great percentage let's do
something nicer yeah all right 60 yeah
that looks better so there you can have
as many segments as you want still one
line of code and that spec is in CSS
images level four and actually it has
many nice examples it has the pie chart
as an example I made sure I I added this
so I made sure to include that you can
even have repeating gradients which may
likely do starbursts you contribute
checker boards with conic gradients so
let's evaluate this solution flexibility
wise wanted to change the colors one
edit to change the size wanted to change
the value we can set it in line you can
just set the gradient no extra elements
only three declarations the other two of
which are border radius and padding very
straightforward just one line multiple
values are possible super easy to
animate just animate the colors top
position some effects are possible you
can just instead of doing the same color
stop just do two and then you can have a
small gradient okay that's sort of a bad
thing about it
the effects are difficult but still
overall it's a pretty awesome solution
except one little thing this is the
browser support
yeah come on come on browsers please
especially Microsoft can implement it
more easily than any others and actually
Microsoft has put it on the backlog
which means they are actually actively
interested in their planning to work on
it and you know how it works once one
browsers it implements it the others
follow here's you where you come in
actually many developers think that
browsers decide what to implement in a
vacuum and it doesn't matter what
developers want what developers want is
the primary motivation for prioritizing
what to implement sure if developers
want something that's super difficult to
implement like a parent selected like
the parent selector yeah that's that's
more difficult to get browsers to do to
do it but in general browsers have teams
that whose entire jobs are to monitor
what developers want every browser maybe
except Apple because Apple doesn't
really care but every browser has a
developer relations team which whose
main purpose is to connect with
developers see what they want bring it
back to the browser so where do you
where do you come in you can you can
tweet about it you can vote on
Microsoft's user voice which actually
all the browser's follow it not just
Microsoft you can vote on the bugs if
you have anything useful to add you
cannot comment on the bug reports there
are bug reports on with every major
browser on this your voice matters as
long as you make as long as you make
sure that you're heard it matters and
you can make browsers implement what
matters to you and that doesn't just
apply to connect gradients it applies to
anything it's like the closest thing we
have to direct democracy so the other
thing is okay like I've just said no
browser implements connect gradients so
what was I showing you right now I mean
have you've seen that my slides are
basically an HTML page in chrome so what
was I showing
what is this so I've actually made and
released a polyfill it's on this address
don't get hub and there's even it works
with prefix-free but there's also a post
CSS plugin we're using the same code you
can you don't you can play with it
directly on the page these are live okay
that's a bad choice these are live you
can edit them right there if you want to
experiment with conic gradients so after
spending 40 something minutes telling
you how to make pie charts I actually
pie charts a good idea how many here
have heard of Edward Tufte he's like the
information visualization master he is a
very big name in information
visualization he's written tons of books
he runs tons of workshops so one of the
things he's often quoted as saying he
wrote it this way in one of his books a
table is nearly always better than a
dumb pie chart the only worse design
than a pie chart is several of them for
then the viewer is asked to compare
quantities located in spite in spatial
disarray I will explain what this means
shortly both within and between pies
given their low data density and failure
to order numbers along the visual
dimension pie charts should never be
used okay he does have a point he's not
always right he's not right in every
case there are several exceptions but he
does have a point look at this pie chart
which slice is bigger which slice is
smaller can you rank can you order them
based on an order of which percentages
in an in order of size of percentage
they're very similar right it's hard to
do it with a bar chart you can instantly
see that they're actually the same and
I've been trolling you all along what
about this one which one's smaller which
one's bigger it's kind of hard to tell
with a bar chart you can we can do it
instantly well yes this applies when you
have a pie chart of multiple percentages
very close to each other when you want
to show a trend pie charts are great
when you only want to show two
percentages maybe three and they're not
that close together but you want to show
a trend pie charts can be a good idea
and in some cases pie charts shine if
you want to show whether it's if the
important bit is whether something is
lower or higher than 50% this is much
easier to show with a pie chart than it
is with a bar chart however does it
really matter this top was never really
about pie charts right thank you very
much